I know I mentioned it briefly already
but this steak is very expensive are you
trying to sell it
[Applause]
[Music]
famous birds marveled fat and buttery
texture Wagyu has taken over everything
from fancy sliders to expense accounts
takes the highest level ingredients fry
them all put them on a plate serve them
up I'll eat but what separates the real
stuff from wanna BYU today I'm on a
mission to better understand the complex
world of Japanese beef and to start I'm
meeting with hot ones host Sean Evans at
psycho my to try the restaurants viral
$85 Wagyu katsu Sando
[Music]
so Shawn are you ready this is the
fabled $85 Wagyu katsu Sando you had me
at 85% which have you had loggia before
you know sometimes I'll end up in Lakers
Suites that may be a little bit above my
paygrade end up with like a Wagyu slider
it's very like that's sort of I guess
mochi night out sort of thing so come
across ragu in the past but I'm excited
hey but not like this before no no this
is this is interesting to me even like
the precision the order everything about
it right I'm surprised too this is the
first time for myself as well shall we
go for it let's go let's go for it Sokka
Meyers Wagyu katsu Sando is made with a
five miyazaki Wagyu a six ounce cut of
strip loin is dunked in batter
covered in panko breadcrumbs and
deep-fried the steak has been covered in
tonkatsu sauce and sandwiched between
two slices of shook foam or milk bread
[Music]
mmm this is bomb this is awesome Wow hmm
it's so rich yeah it's so tasty I'm
gonna end up finishing this afterwards
what I'm going to finish this whole
sandwich I like the crispness on the
outside the tender meat on the inside
and - it's pretty it is pretty
when I first saw while you conscious on
dose I kind of didn't understand it
because katsu it's so casual and normal
and it's like chicken cutlets and pork
cutlets as always in bentos but to mix
it with something like Wagyu that I feel
like there's almost an academic correct
way to be consuming something so
high-end that combining them confused me
and I wasn't sure if it was like
sacrilegious to be like deep frying
Wagyu meat but now that I've had it I
don't know I'm sold
you're so magic is here why do you think
Wagyu is not only super coveted but also
this expensive like this is this is an
expensive sandwich I have no idea I'm
gonna be real with you I have absolutely
no I didn't either me neither I was kind
of hoping you had an answer for me I
guess I'm gonna go do some research I
would figure this out
I'll even figure out okay good luck
Raina hey we'll miss you
in hopes of answering some of my
questions I'm meeting journalist Larry
Olmstead for a true while you crash
course Larry is the author of the book
real food fake food and an expert on how
real Wagyu found its way into
restaurants in the u.s. at Japan premium
beef butcher Kota Fuji has agreed to
show Larry NIH's some of his finest cuts
of meat Hi Larry Kota thank you so much
for joining me today at you can premium
beef to help me kind of uncover the
mythos behind Wagyu which I know very
very little about and I thought maybe we
could start with some terminology that's
perhaps misused or maybe miscategorized
sure I think that the biggest confusion
comes from Kobe beef which is the most
famous of Japanese beef Kobe beef is
Wagyu but not all Wagyu is Kobe beef and
I think it's easy to compare to say wine
right you have good wine from Sonoma and
Napa but they're just different places
Kobe is a place and all of the major
kinds of Japanese Wagyu are named for
the region's they come from got it so
going back a little bit to the cows that
are involved I hear that they're treated
very well that they're given massages
and that perhaps has something to do
with their meat structure and like the
marbling that is a myth some of them are
massage some of them are given beer
those are the things you hear that's
really just up to the rancher it's not
certainly not all Japanese Wagyu is
massaged over listens to classical music
or drinks beer these are the kind of
things you hear and that is not where
the marbling comes from you know there
is a belief that the less stress the
happier the cow the better it tastes so
you know if we're drinking beer and
losing the classical music oh that
of course of course that's not the norm
I see so what does kind of affect the
marbling or honestly the flesh of what
happens to the cattle it's really
genetics that's the big thing that's
what makes Wagyu Wagyu and there are
four major breeds of Japanese cattle but
for example Kobe the all of the Kobe
beef is produced by a bloodline that has
been 100% intact for over 700 years it
might help to actually see a piece this
is a five music you a GU there's so much
fat everywhere it almost looks like
fatty tuna
you know at times we get a steak and
people like the outside edge because
it's where the fat is here it's
everywhere
and because Wagyu is also higher and
unsaturated fat than American beef which
melts at a lower temperature it melts
more quickly on your tongue so when
people say oh it melts in your mouth
it's literally true it really does it
does definitely feel like butter yeah so
I know that Japan premium beef also has
some domestic Wagyu which is kind of an
interesting new evolution I think in
this world of Wagyu can we take a look
at that sure so this is New York Strip
okay don't mystical argue amazing and is
there some kind of crossbreeding that
happened perhaps in order to create this
almost hybrid yeah there is and one of
the reasons is because it is so fatty
and so rich and you know we're a culture
that typically you eat a steak a person
especially when you go out where's you
know in Japan it would be sliced up and
you would get some slices we don't
really do that especially at home as
much in the US by crossbreeding with the
Angus you reduce the amount of fattiness
so this is kind of the gateway drug
where you get that fattiness experience
but you still get to eat a bigger piece
of red meat that we're used to
[Music]
kudos Allah who's named Tokina well you
don't already talked about Alaska like a
whole day
so listen Ed beaucoup van you horny
tataki man that's your grandmother fun
schedule hi yeah buddy run yet the
Technion danube is a large scale how
many cups there are no new clarity
Guinea but on total money especially no
cage on that plane were you able to talk
about the taboo which by one disability
well Larry thank you so much for
enlightening me and coda thank you so
much for presenting this incredible slab
of meat for us so appreciated how do you
lose I gotta go throw something
[Music]
for my next stop I'm heading to old
homestead the oldest continuously
running steak house in the country where
a $350 hunk of Wagyu is served like a
New York Strip there's only one person
worth treating to a meal this pricey and
that's my friend and former mentor
philip defranco phil has just returned
from his trip to Japan and we're both
anxious to see if NYC's most expensive
steak is really worth the price tag I'm
mark Shari one of the co-owners here at
the old homestead
and I'm Greg Shari the other corner we
are are in the Meatpacking District
right here restaurant has been here
since 1868 and we started with
developing a great relationship with the
butchers all of the beef from out west
was right over here so we had the
opportunity to have the first pick of
the finest meats our signature cuts here
are all our revised our fillets they're
all USDA prime and I said to Gregg Gregg
we got to go up one step what can we do
we have been hearing about Kobe beef for
years and I said Greg I think that if we
could bring a New York style Kobe steak
to New York City it would be a smash
finally we got the okay in 1991 and was
an amazing situation we charged one
hundred and fifty dollars a stake at
that time we ran with our Kobe beef for
about 10 15 years and then I looked at
him and I said we got to go to the next
level we are the only restaurant that's
allowed to go to Japan and bid on prized
Wagyu I go suitcase of money I've been
on it I get it and we send it here and
that's where it all exploded I mean it
was waiting lists we couldn't get the
meat here as fast as we wanted it and
that's what kicked off the old homestead
with being the king of beef when it
comes to Wagyu and since I spent so much
time there
I got nicknamed mr. Rago the $350 neck
it's been featured all over the world
that someone has had prized Wegg girl
like a New York sirloin that's the
melting of the two cuisines
[Music]
[Music]
so thank you so much for joining me for
dinner today thanks for having me so
excited that you flew in all the way for
me and for steak
yes I mean it's it's kind of a 50/50
situation I appreciate both of you I
know how I was able to kind of tip the
scales in my favor mistake yeah
have you ever had Wagyu before yes but I
don't think I've had this this specific
kind and cut I actually had a lot of
questions about Wagyu because there's a
lot of more to it so little a little bit
of research and there are about four
native Japanese cows and I believe that
this is the highest class you can get
300 50 bucks for steak that's
intimidating can we dig in alright Wow
The Simpsons say there's so there's so
much fat in the best way that's the
whole thing with Wagyu is the marbling
Thank You moose
[Music]
Wow what do you feel it it's so buttery
which is such an interesting way to
describe steak but it melts in your
mouth I was told it would melt in my
mouth but I didn't understand because of
the fibers but what's crazy I've never I
don't know what to think it's like
scaring me it melted it's gone you're
like that's not what steaks supposed to
do no ma'am oh my good is this medium
rare it is I can tell
[Music]
will not cook the steak anything brother
medium-rare well done sorry you're at
the wrong place the 350 we don't want to
take a chance of ruining the world what
if the customer says it's my 350 doesn't
matter our reputation is important we
don't put anything but a little salt and
pepper on it's hot sear very important
if you want to sear both sides see the
juices it cook it a little bit more than
medium rare rare that's well it's like
you're live forth in your mouth when you
think the fireworks are over it keeps
coming it keeps coming and when you
think it's over
there comes the finale the taste never
stops you just can't imagine a phantom
how much flavor this beef has
[Music]
the last time that I had Waku I got it
at a lager place where they didn't serve
like this they they cut it up and then
you cooked it in front of you okay so
you had Wagyu in Japan yes that's legit
how was it that's great I mean this this
is still top-notch just because the the
cooking was handled by a professional
and not me oh okay
every time other than this time when I
when I have ordered a Wagyu steak
they they always tell me that but they
say this stuff about like it's been from
a specific part Japan yeah and they only
say the massage thing if they feed them
sake I want them to just do that with
more like more food more food like
salmon come from yeah always its mental
state oh yeah maybe feel in general and
in the final moments it's a dark
[Music]
in America my cattle is what we quote
force-fed they want to rush the cattle
to 1200 1600 pounds quickly as possible
to sell it
this meat is 12 months and 14 months
they do not rush the cattle as you could
see the marbling is very equal that
means it can slowly fed hops rain they
keep it in a scientifically controlled
pens it's not too hot it's not too cold
so really it's like a spot the cattle
this cattle it's like a superstar he's
got his own stall he's got a fan they
give him beer stimulate his appetite
he's not running around with the herd
each one is separately taken care of
with the utmost respect and at the end
of the day when you treat something that
way that's what you get the best
[Music]
I know I mentioned it briefly already
but this steak is very expensive trying
to sell it know it is so expensive and
it's easily the most expensive thing
I've ever eaten it's like it's rich it's
tasty but it's not overwhelming to the
point where I'm like I need to stop
right right like I need to stop and
overcook this for breakfast with eggs
like I would just make sure the
conversation lasts too long you can
slowly work wait wait would you pay this
much normally in my everyday life no I
would not but it was me and a group of
friends right and it was like we were
celebrating something right it's more of
like the emotion in the experience yeah
not because of the price I'm very frugal
with my money but in a hypothetical
situation right yes you're paying for
the experience
yes yeah I totally agree with that I
feel like maybe a lot of people don't
know our relationship but it was the
absolute experience of a lifetime to not
only intern for you but also to have you
who asked me to audition for SourceFed
that obviously changed my life
so this steak dinner was to thank you
for everything they've done for me it's
one of those things where I think near
the end of it I start really appreciate
it the most of like okay this is this
was a special time right cuz you don't
always fully appreciate it so I'm glad
that it happened well Phil thank you
again so much for joining me
it was awesome catching up I believe
it's been two years it's a nice end to a
a great day
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much for watching go Chi
Cheng I so appreciate it Sean should
they like and subscribe like and
subscribe or else thank you